built into the caves of Crimea's
balaclava Bay lies a cold war submarine
bunker the Russians started building it
in 1957 it took four years to complete
and was designed to take a direct atomic
strike after a period of decay the
Russians gifted it to the Western
leaning Ukrainians who turned it into
the Cold War Museum Russia is now in
control of Crimea for the time being at
least the base is still a museum I
dropped in for an unexpected incognito
visit obviously very secret base and the
motto is don't say everything you know
and always know what you say in fact the
place was so secretive workers relatives
were barely able to visit paperwork and
thick walls got in the way the whole
base could be hermetically sealed with
these doors and people could stay inside
in the case of a nuclear attack for 3
years Russia has always had a naval base
in Crimea called the Black Sea Fleet
even when it was under Ukrainian control
now Crimea is under Russian control it's
getting bigger with all the talk that
the US and Russia are entering a new
Cold War visiting the Cold War Museum
was more than a little daunting after
the annexation the whole base was
transferred to Russia's Black Sea Fleet
the question now is will it remain a
museum or something else